to his supporters he's a bastian of
press freedom to his detractors a
criminal who put lives at risk this
latest twist in julian assange's legal
saga further sharpening that debate
julian is unquestionably a political
prisoner
he's not
you know a criminal
he's somebody who's done something that
doesn't fit with powerful forces assange
is wanted in america on spy charges
after releasing millions of classified
government documents in 2010
among the wikileaks revelations footage
of u.s troops firing on and killing
civilians during the iraq war as well as
the private thoughts of america's
diplomats the world over
washington claims assange endangered
vulnerable sources by sharing the files
unredacted
fearing extradition assange sought
asylum in london's ecuadorian embassy
where he would stay for seven years
occasionally appearing on his balcony to
address the world's media below
extradition without charge
is not something that we expect from the
rule of law in the united kingdom
he was originally arrested on rape
allegations from sweden charges that
were later dropped but by 2019 assange
had overstayed his welcome at the
embassy and was evicted arrested and
jailed for jumping bail
since then he's been held in belmar high
security prison where in april he
married lawyer stella morris with whom
he had two children while hiding in the
embassy
during his incarceration here assange's
legal team say his health has suffered
significantly claiming he's lost a lot
of weight and suffered a stroke but they
fear that extradition to the us would
take a far greater toll on him and have
previously argued in court it would make
him a suicide risk
jennifer robinson has represented him
since the start and will now appeal his
extradition claiming assange could face
up to 175 years behind bars if found
guilty in the u.s it sets a dangerous
precedent it means that any journalist
in this country could be prosecuted and
extradited to a foreign country for
releasing truthful information
information about war crimes human
rights abuse and corruption and this
government should not allow it to go
ahead but experts say legally speaking
the home secretary had little choice but
to approve the us request
it's effectively a rubber stamping
exercise so the arguments around the
treatment he will receive in the us
whether this is for political reasons
that's not actually something she can
consider i can't see on the current
powers of the home sector under the
extradition act that she could refuse it
but that doesn't mean assange will be on
a plane anytime soon after appealing
here he can also go to the european
court of human rights his legal limbo
isn't over yet iva bennett sky news